Musik Okay, eins, zwei, drei, Ufo! Lustig! Herzlich willkommen zu der neuen Folge, das Podcast Ufo. Richtig. Heute zu Gast, ihr kennt vielleicht aus X-Faktor das Unfassbare, als Co-Moderator der Stefan-Titze-Show, als Darsteller im Smash Mouth Walking on the Sun Musikvideo. Er hat jetzt sein eigenes Buch, sein eigenes Album ist rausgekommen, wurde in 13 Sprachen übersetzt, und er ist König der Heuschrecken. Hier ist meine Damen und Herren, fügen Sie Ihre Hände ruckartig zusammen für Sturr-Raf-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-O-R-F-Titze-Experience. Und er ist König der Heuschrecken. Hier ist, meine Damen und Herren, fügen Sie Ihre Hände ruckartig zusammen für Stefan-Titze. Oh mein Gott, vielen Dank. Dankeschön, bleibt ruhig sitzen. Im Ernst, bleibt sitzen. Sitzen doch. Okay, gegenüber von mir gibt's mal wieder den einen, den unfassbaren, ihr kennt ihn von Kultformaten, mag ich sagen, wie Verflixte Flicks oder unter anderem auch Last September in Monaco, das Erfolg Soundcloud-Format. Dann kennt ihr ihn auch zum Beispiel aus der Werbung, der Captain Morgan Werbung oder aus diversenkohol-Werbungen im Fernsehen, weil das sein Ding ist.
Herzlich willkommen, Florentin Bill. Hallo, vielen Dank. Dann freut mich, hier sein zu dürfen. Was gibt's Neues in deinem Leben? Also, wir machen heute mal eine Folge ohne Schneiden. Ihr werdet nicht glauben, was mir passiert ist. Da gehe ich doch letztens tatsächlich in den Supermarkt. Und dann nehme ich mir einen Tkühl-Spinat aus der Tiefkühltheke, also aus dieser Box. Und zack, war er nicht mehr gefroren. Diese grossen Boxen, wo man dann oben so diesen Schieber hat, wo man dann reingreift und dann ist es ein bisschen kühl. TK-Boxen. TK heissen die? Tiefkühlboxen. Ah, da kennst du die Abkürzung dafür. Ja, klar. Ich interessiere mich für Leute und frage dann auch oft mal auch Mitarbeiterinnen, was macht ihr da gerade, sorry, wie ändert man das? Weil ich interessiere mich auch immer, wie sehen Jobs aus von Leuten, die das professionell machen. Also du hast eine MA gefragt. Ich habe eine MA gefragt, die gerade eine TK gelehrt hat mit ihrem EW Einkaufswagen. War eine Kundin, die hat sich herausgestellt. Auf jeden Fall habe ich den TK geö und habe dann R und dann habe ich den S rausgenommen und dann dachte ich mir, das war ganz schön kalt gerade. Aber es war relativ schnell vorbei, weil ich habe meine Hand dann auch wieder rausgenommen. Also auch immer Angst, dass bei diesen automatisch zugehenden Boxen deinen Arm, dass du deinen Arm verlierst. So sind tatsächlich vier meiner Brüder, haben alle ihre Arme verloren. Das war ein bisschen unglücklich, alle gleichzeitig, aber man kann nichts machen. Und dann wurde ihr genannt, die Familie … Die armlosen Brüder. Einarmiger Bandit, einarmiger Bruder … Willst du wirklich nicht schneiden, bist du dir sicher, dass du nicht schneiden willst, so dass nicht ein bisschen zu früh gesagt wird? Leute … Ach, ich freue mich, ich freue mich, dass wir wieder zusammensetzen. Wir haben letzte Woche keine Folge rausgehauen, quasi, also keine neue. Wir haben vorher zwei Wochen aufgenommen. Der Druck der Öffentlichkeit war zu hoch, einfach der Fokus auf die Sendung und der Moderator war zu gross und da haben wir uns gedacht, nee, das können wir nicht machen. Und deswegen müssen wir sagen … Es war alles nur ein Fake. … sind wir jetzt quasi den Leuten eine Superfolge schuldig. Doppelfolge. Eine super duper Doppelfolge. Das ist so ein bisschen wie wenn man Milchpulver in Milch auflöst. So das ist Doppelmilch. Und genau so ist die heutige Folge, ist eine Doppelfolge. Das ist sozusagen, man kann die einzelnen Spuren noch mal trennen. Das finde ich interessant, Kakaopulver in Kakao auflösen. Wäre dann Kakao einfach starker Kakao. Kartoffelpulver in Backpulver im Backofen auflösen. Oder so Instant-Tee in Chante. Tee, schon T Liegt da was? Liegt da im Wirt? Oder zum Beispiel einen Teebeutel in Cola auflösen zum Beispiel, also wirklich intensiv. In Red Bull auflösen vielleicht. Oh, das glaube ich, oder halt in Kaffee kochen, aber statt mit Wasser mit Red Bull. Da glaube ich... Oder statt Milch Pfanta in den Kaffee. Oder einen Pfannkuchen, und man benutzt statt Mehl Kakao. Nikotin. Oder aufgelöst oder Schwarzpulver. Wow. Ich glaube, das ist eine explosive Mischung. Oder man trinkt statt Red Bull einfach einen Liter Kerosin. Ja. Energie, Energie. Oder man steigt auf eine zwei Meter Höhe. Energieerhaltungssatz. Leiter einfach. Wenn du im Mittelalter wärst, glaubst du, du könntest sagen, hey Leute, das mit den Schwertern und so, das ist totaler Quatsch, ihr könnt auch Schwarzpulver benutzen, könntest du aus dem Stand Schwarzpulver herstellen? Ich habe, glaube ich, bis vor kurzem gedacht, dass Pistolen über Luftdruck funktionieren. Das stimmt tatsächlich. Deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass ich den Leuten das erklären hätte. Also ich hätte sehr schlau getan, wäre aber nie konkret geworden, wie so Silicon Valley, uncooler Silicon Valley Typen, die immer behaupten, sie hätten die grossartige Startup-Idee oder App-Idee. Und wenn man sie fragt, wären sie aber nie konkret, weil die eigentlich gar nicht so eine geile Idee haben und es nach außen so tun, als hätten sie die mega Ideen hätten, würden sie nicht trauen, dass andere das vielleicht klauen könnten. Und so wäre ich im Mittelalter auch, ein Riesenarschloch. Ja, ich habe nicht mal in so einer Reaktionskonferenz mit Stefan wie immer eigentlich meinen Mittel und Zeigefinger zur Pistole geformt, an die Schläfe gehalten und piu-piu-piu gesagt. Und dann habe ich so getan, als würde ich ein neues Magazin anlegen, um ihm nochmal zwölf Schüsse zu geben. Und er hat gesagt, ah, in dem Magazin, da ist die Luft drin, ne? Wieder bitte? Ja, da ist die Druckluft drin, damit man schießen kann. Ja, das war ein Scherz von mir. Und dann hat sich herausgestellt, dass Stefan tatsächlich davon ausgeht, dass auch normale Schusswaffen mit Druckluft funktionieren. Also ich weiss nicht, wo er denkt, dass die Kugeln deponiert sind, aber er dachte wirklich, dass in dem Magazin nur neue Druckluft ist. Nee, ich dachte auch, also beides dachte ich tatsächlich. Weil das einzige, was ich kenne, ich bin nicht so eine Waffenfamilie wie du, wie ihr. Waffenstarrend, bis an die Zähne über Waffen jeden Tag. Genau, wo man dann immer, wo du morgen schon quasi am Büroeingang schon die ganze Waffen hinlegen musst. So bin ich nicht drauf. Ich bin nämlich eher so der, wir hatten, wir haben nach dem Teneriffa-Urlaub, hatten mein Vater und ich, als ich noch relativ klein war, haben wir uns, weil man da auch schießen konnte. Da gibt es dann diese Freizeitaktivitäten und ich habe das Schießen geliebt und habe dann mir so eine CO2-Pistole gekauft. Und daher kommt man halt unten, kommen immer die CO2-Patronen rein. Weil du die Umwelt hast und den Klimawandel einfach. Seitdem habe ich geglaubt, quasi wow, so funktionieren all so Knarren. Und dann hat sich herausgestellt, dass die echten, die Walter P99, eigentlich ganz anders funktioniert, als ich dachte. Aber ich habe auch nicht wirklich darüber nachgedacht. Also Waffen spielen in meinem Leben nicht so eine grosse Rolle. Aber bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, dass du diese Gaspistole in der Hand hattest, hast du nur mit Wasserspritzpistolen gearbeitet und du dachtest, so würde das funktionieren. Da wäre es flüssiges Blei in den Pistolen, die man einfach durch die Kraft seines Fingern hinaus... Statt Wasser haben die einfach jetzt Blei reingemacht. Ja, ganz einfach. Das erhärtet in der Luft und... Durch die Geschwindigkeit. Ich beziehe immer alles auf die Dinge, die ich gerade damit am nächsten verbinde. Was ist die effektivste Waffe? Ist es Psychologie? Worte. Ja, Worte. Worte sind eine Waffe. Wer hat gesagt? Trotsky. Du hast ja mal gesagt, meine Worte sind mein Schwert, aber ein sehr stumpfes. Wie hast du das gemeint? Ich habe, glaube ich, gesagt, wenn Worte meine Sprache wären, wären Worte gegebenenfalls eine Sprache. Ich muss kurz mal den Strom nehmen. Sonst geht der Sendeablauf aus und dann stehe ich da, verloren im Podcastdschungel und dann brauche ich auch erstmal eine Taschenlampe in diesem Podcast, in dieser Metapher, die ich jetzt verloren habe. Ich habe eine Frage vergessen. Kann ich auf eine andere antworten? Mir geht es sehr gut. Also ich bin gelassen, es war eine ruhigere Woche für uns mal. Man konnte sich so ein bisschen auch mal ausruhen, hinlegen eine Runde. Schlafen, einfach mal ausruhen. Schlafen. Sich mal auf die seichte Schulter legen und mal einfach ausruhen, einfach chillaxen. Wie schläfst du? Wie kann man sich das vorstellen? Sehr schlecht. Auf dem Bauch, auf der Seite, auf dem Rücken? Nee, auf der Seite. Und angeblich ist man ja, wenn man Rechtshänder ist, schläft man auf der linken Seite besser. Und deswegen, immer wenn ich auf der rechten Seite liege, denke ich, ich schlafe eh nicht ein, das ist eh Zeitverschwendung. Findest du diese Fakten immer oder hast du die wirklich mal irgendwo gelesen? Nee, die hat mir jemand hier auf dem Wiki gesagt. Er hat gesagt so, hier pass mal auf, folgendes, Rechtshänder schlafen auf der linken Seite besser. Du hast gesagt eben auf dem Hinweg, kann ich zwei Club-Mater haben und können Sie mir bitte sagen, auf der Seite man besser schläft als Rechtshänder. Genau, und deswegen, wenn ich auf der rechten Seite liege, denke ich mir immer, erst gut ist eigentlich Zeitverschwendung, weil ich kann jetzt eh nicht einschlafen. Das heisst, ich muss jetzt eigentlich nur die Zeit überbrücken, um mich wieder auf die linke Seite drehen zu können. Weil es dann wieder cooler ist, weil wenn man länger auf der rechten Seite liegt, desto cooler fühlt sich dann die linke Seite an. Ja, wobei man sich eigentlich fragen kann, warum man nicht unendlich lange auf einer Seite liegen kann. Und ich dachte früher immer als Kind, dass das gesamte Blut in dem Körper auf eine Seite halt so runter fließt und man sich dann irgendwann umdrehen muss, weil sonst die linke Körperhälfte einfach kein Blut mehr hat und man muss sich wieder auf die andere Seite drehen und dann fliesst wieder ganz langsam das ganze Blut auf die andere Seite runter. Aber auf der einen Seite ist es gar nicht so einfach zu beantworten, weil eigentlich, ausser zu allem, dass man Druck auf die Körperseite ausübt durch die Schwerkraft, die Gravitation, die Gravitation, hat man eigentlich kein Problem, weil man kann nicht unendlich lange auf einer Körperseite liegen. Ich habe, glaube ich, irgendwann mal verlernt, mich umzudrehen. Ich habe nämlich irgendwann darüber nachgedacht, als ich dann lag im Bett, wie ich mich gerade umgedreht habe. Man macht das ja unbewusst irgendwie. Ich habe mir bewusst gemacht, wie das gerade passiert ist, weil ich habe keine Muskeln benutzt, meiner Meinung nach, aber man dreht sich einfach irgendwie. Ich habe keine bewussten Muskeln ausgelöst. Du hast deinen Körper ohne Muskeln benutzt. Und dann habe, und dann habe ich irgendwie nachgedacht, wie man das macht, und seitdem habe ich, glaube ich, verlernt, wie man sich umdreht, und da bin ich immer so ganz seltsam um und habe immer so ganz viele, weiss ich nicht, so seltsam unnötige Bewegungen mache ich dabei. Es ist tatsächlich interessant, und genau das gleiche hatte ich auch, und ich habe die Beinscheren-Strategie entwickelt. Und zwar, du scherst deine Beine aus, also du klappst sie so aus, als würdest du laufen, und dann hast du ja sozusagen einen Hebel. Dann machst du einen drüber. Genau, dann hast du einen Hebel, dann liegst du so da und dann kannst du die Füsse einfach für sich drehen und dadurch dreht sich automatisch ein Oberkörper, weil du ja den Hebel ansetzt, weil deine Beine weiter auseinander sind. Klepper. Und dadurch drehst du dich um und dann klappst du die Beine wieder zusammen wie so ein Taschenmesser und dann bist du durch eigentlich. Ich mach's ruckartig, wie so ein Fisch, wenn man Comic-Fische aus dem Wasser zieht und dann sind die immer auf dem Boden und machen so ... Zappeln, ja. Zappeln halt. So mache ich das auch quasi. Also ich bewege meinen Oberkörper so ein bisschen hoch und schmeiße mich dann auf die Seite. Du setzt das Gelenk in der Körpermitte an und klappst dich dann so um. Auch wie ein Messer, nur halt ein grösseres. Genau wie so eine Schere. Also ich mache meinen Oberkörper so ein bisschen hoch und dann so ein bisschen drüber. Schere. Schere darfst du in diesem Podcast nicht sagen, das wissen wir schon.
Wir wurden der Zensur bezichtigt.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich früher bei anderen Leuten übernachtet habe als Kind, dann habe ich mich immer total eingeengt gefühlt, weil ich immer dachte, dass mich alle anderen konstant beobachten.
Ja, und ich dachte immer, die beobachten mich konstant und merken alles, was ich tue.
Und man weiß ja nicht, ob man normal schläft oder nicht, weil man bis zu dem Alter von, sag ich mal, 26 schläft man ja eigentlich immer nur alleine. Und ab dann auch ab und zu mit anderen Leuten zusammen. Und dann weiss man ja gar nicht, ob man normal schläft, weil man bis dahin keinen Vergleich hatte. Und deswegen dachte ich immer, die beobachten mich immer sehr stark, ob ich irgendwas anders mache. Und deswegen habe ich dann immer... Sag ein bisschen was über dich aus, dass du immer denkst, dass du beobachtet wirst von anderen, als ob du irgendwie wichtiger wärst als die, weil die auch schlafen wollen.
Bisschen seltsam.
Aber was ihr mal ausprobieren könnt jetzt, legt euch mal auf den Rücken und legt dann mal euren Arm so angewinkelt, dass euer Unterarm nach oben zeigt, in die Luft, so wie so ein Turm.
Ja?
Macht das jetzt mal bitte.
Ich bin nach oben schüttert.
Egal, ob ihr jetzt in der U-Bahn seid oder gerade auf dem Trucker-Trop nachliegt, legt euch jetzt mal auf den Rücken. Machen wir mal kurz die Augen zu. Eure Lieder werden ganz schwer. Stellt euch vor, ihr liegt auf einem grossen Schwamm, so wie in der Spür liegt. Ihr liegt auf einem riesigen Schwamm und ihr sinkt langsam ein in diesen Schwamm. Erst euer Körper, dann die Arme, dann die Beine und der Kopf und ihr sinkt ganz tief. Plötzlich hingelt euer Handy mit einem schrillen Ton, ihr drückt es weg, ach, es nervt, immer muss in Anruf zu einer Spannungssession stören. Ihr singt wieder weiter ein, ihr singt drei Meter, fünf Meter, ihr singt ganz tief, alles um euch herum verändert sich, ihr hört plötzlich die Hymne der Internationalen Kommunistischen Partei. We will rock you. Und we will rock you in a medley, in a mashup, was ist das? Nee, das ist die Hymne der Internationalen Kommunistischen Partei. Ihr könnt es nicht ganz genau hören, auf jeden Fall, ihr fallt durch eine Decke und ihr seid plötzlich in einer anderen Welt. Ihr guckt euch um und es ist alles ganz seltsam, denn alles … Es ist ein bisschen gleich, ihr seid in einem Multiversum. Es ist eine Art Multiversum, aber alle Multiversen sind in einem Universum kombiniert, sozusagen. Alles, was ihr euch vorstellt, ist gleichzeitig und ist existiert nicht. Jeder Gegenstand hat alle Farben gleichzeitig. Und hat sie nicht und existiert wiederum nicht. existiert und existiert aber auch nicht. Es ist eine komplett dialektische Welt, in der alles ist und gleichzeitig nicht ist. Vor euch steht … Und wir machen die Augen wieder auf, stehen wieder auf, ihr schüttelt euch kurz, schüttelt den Arm, schüttelt die Beine oder ihr legt euch auf den Rücken und stellt euren Unterarm so auf, dass er in die Luft zeigt, so wie so ein Turm, und dann versucht ihr mal, eure Muskeln schlagartig nicht mehr anzuspannen, sodass der Arm umfällt. So, und jetzt achtet mal drauf, wie der Arm umfällt. Und ich wette mit euch, ihr kriegt es nicht hin, dass der Arm wirklich authentisch umfällt, weil ihr immer automatisch, dadurch dass ihr euren Arm beobachtet, ihr könnt gar nicht anders, als mit euren Muskeln zu kontrollieren, wie er fällt. Ihr habt ein Bild im Kopf, wie ein Arm umfallen sollte, und so fällt er um. Ihr kriegt es nicht hin. Zum Beispiel wenn du jetzt, wenn du jetzt einen Schauspieler sollst so tun, als würde er erschossen, Kopfschuss, er hat sofort von einer Sekunde auf den nächsten versagen alle Muskeln des Körpers und er sackt in sich zusammen. Ich behaupte, das ist unmöglich zu spielen, weil du natürlich nicht alle Muskeln ausschalten kannst und weil du ein Bild im Kopf hast, wie jemand umfällt und das automatisch so lenkst, auch unterbewusst, das automatisch so lenkst, dass du so hinfällst. Heißt das, wenn du viele Comedy-Sendungen guckst, wo ja sehr viel quasi überspitzt dargestellt wird, du dann auch anfängst, Comedy-mäßig zu gehen, weil du Dinge, die eigentlich automatisch ablaufen, dir abguckst, unterbewusst dann doch eigentlich. Absolut, ich glaube schon. Deswegen gehen wir lustig. Ich glaube, in Filmen zum Beispiel, wenn Leute erschossen werden, dann fallen sie nach hinten um oder so, als hätten sie jetzt irgendeine Wucht bekommen, was ja Quatsch ist, weil die Kugel schlägt ja normalerweise durch den Körper durch und man sagt einfach in einer zusammen. Aber ich glaube auch, dass wenn zum Beispiel du erschossen werden würdest, du reflexartig nach hinten dich werfen würdest. Weil du selbst, wenn du stirbst, cool aussehen würdest. Genau, und weil du denkst, so müsste es aussehen, so würde die Gesellschaft erwarten, dass es aussieht, wenn du erschossen wirst und wirfst dich so.
Die Gesellschaft verlangt von mir, dass ich jetzt ganz doll blute und nach hinten falle. Ja, genau, und das verstirkt. Da reist mir die Wunder auch noch so ein bisschen auf, damit es mir ein bisschen mehr blutet, weil man blutet ja gar nicht so viel. Genau, und halt so einen Schmerzschrei, den normalerweise auch niemand machen würde, sondern du machst einen Schmerzschrei und würdest so sterben wie im Film. Ich glaube, langsam assimiliert der Film die Wirklichkeit und irgendwann die Wirklichkeit wird immer mehr wie ein Film. Und dann gibt es wieder neue Filme. Apropos schlafen, wusstest du, dass es diese Technik gibt, Powernapping?
Du hast einen Schlüsselbund in der Hand, legst dich hin und zwar so, dass der Schlüsselbund über dem Boden ist. So, und dann wartest du so lange, bis du eingeschlafen bist, dann fällt er auf dem Boden, du wachst davon auf von dem Geräusch oder auch nicht, weil du bewusstlos bist, aber normalerweise wachst du davon auf von dem Geräusch und dann hast du quasi so eine ganz, eine Sekunde, so einen ganz kurzen Zeitraum nur im Tiefschlaf verbracht und das ist sozusagen so eine Art Reboot des Körpers. Das nennt man nicht Powernapping. Doch, das nennt man Powernapping und da kannst du halt wohl danach wieder energiegeladen in den Tag gehen, weil du hast keine Zeit verloren, das dauert maximal so zehn, zwölf Minuten, wenn du richtig müde bist und danach bist du halt so gut drauf, als hättest du geschlafen, also wirklich lange geschlafen davor. Das nennt man so. Ich könnte da, glaube ich, im Leben nicht einschlafen, weil ich mich immer auf den Schlüssel konzentrieren würde und immer meine Aufmerksamkeit darauf flinken würde, den festzuhalten und könnte dadurch nicht einsch glaube ich, das geht nicht. Weiss ich nicht. Aber normalerweise soll das so funktionieren.
Kleiner Tipp für euch daraus, probiert das jetzt mal aus.
Wir sind mal kurz zehn Minuten leise. Wow, wow, wow. It's fun, Möwen. Ah!
Ah!
Molekül, Atomkraft, Wasserstoff, Feuerwerk, Zeppelin, Unglück, Tod, Mord. Diese Art von Sketch gibt es schon zu Hunderten. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Doch, habe ich letztens erst gesehen. Wo denn? Auf YouTube. Echt, guckst du mir oft? Also ja, als Parodie auf diese ASMR-Videos. Ach was. Aber dann irgendwie bringt man jemanden um oder ... Du sag mal. Man beschreibt das so und ein Mann läuft hinter dir her und kommt immer näher und so. Du sollst euch dieses Buch empfohlen, wie hieß das nochmal? Welches Buch? Du hast mir ein Buch empfohlen. Die Bibel. Ah, die Bibel. Die wollte ich mir noch holen. Wer hat sich eigentlich den Namen Bibel ausgedacht? Ich glaube, Alter, geiles Buch. Erstmal, nochmal ganz kurz. Sorry, mal nochmal. Lukas, die Idee mit der Kreuzigung. Alter Vater, ich hänge an den, ich konnte es mich nicht weglegen. So, wach mal wieder auf. Glaubst du, dass die vier Evangelien sich quasi überlegt haben, oder lief es so eine Art Konkurrenzkampf ab, so wer schreibt das beste Evangelium? Wer schreibt die besten? Wer schreibt, wer hat die bad, ich will die Kreuzigung drin haben, wer hat die krassesten Szenen, wer hat die krassesten Storys, wer vergisst am meisten Blut, so welches wurde am besten verkauft. Oder, Idee, es gab ja bestimmt noch einen fünften Evangeliker, der aber dann einfach so der behinderte Evangeliker, so der doofe Bruder, der ja, du darfst auch ein Evangelium schreiben, okay, aber der halt nicht in die Bibel genommen wurde, so ja klar darfst du schreiben und dann kommst du auch in die Bibel, genau.
Und der hat halt irgendwas Verrücktes geschrieben und das taucht wieder auf und das würde man dann, also als Idee für einen lustigen Soundcloud-Clip vielleicht, so 18 Minuten lang mit einer Einleitung, am Anfang hört man so Schritte und dann so klopfen, so brr, brr, brr, brr, und dann, ey, wach auf, brr, brr, du musst heute dein Evangelium abgeben, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr. Ah, scheisse, das war heute. Das wirst du dann sagen.
Ah, scheisse, das war heute.
Oh, das muss ich noch abgeben heute.
Dabei bin ich doch erst auf Seite neunhundert vier.
Und weiter geht's achtzehn Minuten lang.
So lange geht es halt noch weiter.
So muss ich mir vorstellen, ey.
Wo du gerade erzählt hast, mit dem Schlafen. ich habe mich gefragt, das frage ich mich schon lange, und es ist wirklich, das brennt auf meiner Haut, diese Frage. Ist Hypnose real? Ja. Weil, ohne Scheiss, ich sehe das immer auf MTV oder diesen seltsamen Sendern, wo man auch nicht weiß, empfange ich die gerade legal oder ist das irgendwie auf so eine Welle im Universum, so eine Raumzeit-Kontinuums-Bruch. Da gibt es immer diese Sendungen, wo ein Hypnotiseur rumläuft und da einfach Leute auf der Strasse, quasi versteckte Kameramäßig, in Tiefschlaf versetzt, denen dann irgendwas Inception-mässig einfläuft in den Gedanken und sowas sagt die, wenn gleich ein Mann mit rotem Ballon an dir vorbeiläuft, dann gibst du... Verspricht sie leider, wenn der berappen Lob mit dem Krams … Wenn jemand gleich, wenn Wolfgang, äh, Tim, gleich bei dir vorbeiläuft, mit dem roten Ballon … Blauen, blauen Schuh. Das ist wirklich so passiert, dann heb 50 Dollar ab, packst du in eine Papiertüte und geh zu dem Mülleimer und schmeiß es da rein und, ähm, ciao. Und dann ist er gegangen und dann ist er wirklich dann aufgewacht, dann kam halt dieser extra, mir nennt man Kumparse, die haben dann vorbeigelaufen mit dem Ballon, mit dem roten Ballon und hat er den gesehen, ist zum Geldautomaten gegangen, hat hundert Dollar abgehoben und die in Papierkauf getan. Wo ich mich wirklich frage, warum geht man dann zum Fernsehen, es kommt der Eismann an. Okay, warte, fuck, der Eismann kommt gerade. Kann man das hören? Hallo, wollt ihr ein Eis kaufen? Es klingt auch immer so ein bisschen nach Gruselkirmes irgendwie. Komm, wir holen uns ein Eis. Das ist eine Kugel Haselnuss für den Stefan. Dankeschön. Bitteschön. Wow. Und ich habe mir eine Kugel Waldmeister geholt. Lass es dir schmecken. Mh, Eis. Grünes Eis. Lecker. Das ist natürlich. Lecker, lecker. Lecker, lecker. Grün ist die beste Farbe für Nahrung. Haben wir uns auch noch nicht gefragt? Wenn man die Wahl hätte, wenn man nur noch von einer Farbe Nahrung zu sich nehmen würde, was man dann für eine Farbe nimmt. Schreibt es in die Kommentare. Ich würde rot nehmen, aber ich würde so sehr rot nehmen, dass ich das nicht begründen möchte. Weil ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass wir alle immer vor der Frage stehen und dann will ich nicht alle rot nehmen. Dann wird aber noch mal die Debatte Rotkohl oder Blöds. Ich habe versucht, ich habe gerade eine eigene Challenge am Laufen, überlegt, die ganze Becher jetzt im Mund zu stecken und das hat funktioniert. Also tut mir leid, aber ich kann Menschen nicht verstehen, die Eis im Becher essen. Was soll das denn? Vor allem, du benutzt ja nicht mehr das kleine Löffelchen, sondern du leckst dann an diesem Becher rum. Weil ich ein Mikrofon halte und dein Penis in der anderen. Was soll ich machen? Hm, lecker lecker. Ja, gut. Das finde ich auch nicht nett. Wenn man mit Kindern spricht, wiederholt man oft Wörter, um sie direkt danach in Wahr zu sagen. Hm, ist das lecker lecker? Das habe ich noch nie gehört, noch nie gemacht. Lecker lecker, igidigit, das sind so Dinge, die man nur zu Kindern sagt. Ja, nur bei igidigit. Igidigit, oh Gott, oh Gott, lecker lecker. Oh Gottchen, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, schieß mich tot, du! Warum sagt man Wörter dann einfach zweimal? Kommt das dann irgendwie deutlicher an? So was meinst du? Wow, wow? Was ist eigentlich Katze? Miau, miau? Mauns, mauns? Hm. Ich glaube, es ist super für die Hörer, uns jetzt beim Eisessen zu gucken. Ich glaube, die Hörer sitzen auch gerade in so einem netten Café, haben sich vielleicht einen Eisbecher geholt mit einer netten Dorme oder dem Jüngling haben die sich geholt. Buben, Buben, Bub, Ulgbub haben die sich von der Strasse geholt und gesagt, du, wollen wir nicht ein Eis essen gehen? Hattest du schon mal ein, das ist das klassische Date, Eis essen gehen im Sommer.
Oder beim Podcast hören, ja, das ist ein klassisches Date.
Hier, ich habe diesen Podcast, wollen wir den zusammen hören?
Ich habe sogar diesen Y-Stecker.
Ah, eine Peitsche nennt man das in der Welt der Tontechniker, nennt man das eine Peitsche, einen Augsverteidiger.
Das nennt man Axt in meiner Erfindung gerade, in meiner, in meiner, in meiner, in meiner Fantasie nennt man das, in der Welt meiner Phantasie. Mit welcher historischen Epoche kennst du dich am wenigsten aus? Äh, Barock, ja, Barock. We will, we will, Barock you, Barock you. Wir fangen ja beide bald nach New York. Und heute, beziehungsweise gestern kam heraus, in welchen Unterkünften wir untergebracht wurden. Und natürlich haben wir die beste Adresse bekommen. Wir haben ein Hotel in München bekommen, leider, was ein bisschen ungünstig ist. Das ist lustig, dass du es ansprichst, aber München wäre, glaube ich, näher dran an Manhattan als das Hotel, wo wir jetzt untergebracht sind. Das ist kein Hotel, das ist in Harlem, einfach eine private Wohnung. Mitten in Harlem einfach, wo man in allen Reiseführern steht, man soll da nicht zu tief reingehen.
Und genau da mittendendrin, haben wir jetzt einen Unterkunft bekommen. Mit Abstand am weitesten weg von allen Unterkünften. Aber weisst du, genau so möchte ich New York erleben. Nicht so in den Touristenströmen mal wieder untergehen, sondern auch mal wirklich da, wo das echte Leben stattfindet. Wo wächst denn so ein Ben Schwartz auf oder Benny Schwartz, wie du sagst? Einfach mal Basketball spielen gehen, in so einem Strassencourt, einfach mal sagen, hey Leute, braucht ihr noch ein Basketballspieler? Nicht, wo ist es schön, wo kriegt man irgendwie so Musical-Tickets hinterhergeworfen. Nein, wo wird man denn führt, wo wird man dann mit Knarre an den Kopf gehalten, wo wird man erschossen, wo muss man einen 10-Euro-Schein in der Jacke haben, damit man die Einbrecher, die überfallen auf der Strasse, die Überfall Überfaller sozusagen, dass man die abschrecken kann. Abschrecken mit 10 Dollar? Ja, einfach. Der hat zu viel Geld, der muss mächtig sein. Ich stand bei so einem Reiseführer, den ich mal hatte, als ich das erste Mal in New York war, dass man immer 10 Dollar irgendwo in der Jacke aufbewahren soll, dass wenn Leute kommen, die das Portemonnaie von dir wollen, du hast kein Portemonnaie dabei, nur diesen 10-euro-Dollarschein. Und dann nehmen die das und sagen, okay, tschau. Du meinst nicht, dass das Kriminelle in den Reiseführer geschrieben haben, sie müssen immer 100 Dollar dabei haben und sofort es dem ersten Schwarzen geben, den sie sehen. Ich habe gehört, man soll zwei Geldbeutel miteinander mit sich rumtragen. Dass man immer einen abgeben kann. Damit die zwei klauen können. Aber ich dachte mir, die Kriminellen sind nicht dumm, nur weil die schwarz sind, heisst es nicht Auto. Ja, aber nicht ganz komplett dumm. Die lesen ja auch die Reiseführer und wissen, dass die Leute zwei Geldbeutel haben und dann müssen die immer, dann schreiben die in der nächsten Auflage, sie müssen immer drei Geldbeutel mitnehmen, damit sie zwei abgeben können. Was ganz geil ist, weil die immer mehr klauen können dadurch auch. Genau. Weil es ist wie im Film, wenn die einen Geldbeutel von denen nehmen, dann stehen sie noch vor dir und sagen, und der nächste? Und du legst dann so den zweiten am Tisch. Wie im Film, wo ich mich auch frage, woher wissen die, dass er noch eine Knarre hat? Ich jetzt nicht gesehen. Wow, in Filmen, wenn die eine Knarre, man eine Knarre hinlegt und dann guckt man sich an und dann ist er auf der Gegend, dass noch eine grössere Knarre kommt und so. Und ich frage mich, wow, wo haben die das gesehen, dass die noch eine Knarre hat? Nehmen Sie bitte genau 17 Geldbeutel mit, wovon in 16 nur ein 5-Euro-Schein ist und ansonsten nichts.
Ja, lustig.
Machen wir da eigentlich noch einen Podcast in New York? In NY, wie ich sage, wie ich selten sage. Nicht wirklich falsch sage.
In Los Angeles, in LA, wie ich sage.
Ja, würde ich sagen. Aber nur eine halbe Stunde irgendwie so.
Weil wir dann so, wir tun dann so busy, dass wir da auch...
Nicht 40 Minuten wie sonst so, nein. Wir müssen gleich noch zum Baseball, so würden wir tun, deswegen würden wir nur eine halbe Stunde irgendwie so. Weil wir dann so, wir tun dann so busy, dass wir da auch. Nicht 40 Minuten wie sonst so. Wir müssen gleich noch zum Baseball, so würden wir tun. Deswegen würden wir nur eine halbe Stunde aufnehmen. Aber jeden Tag würde ich schon sagen. Ich habe mal gelesen, dass Baseballspiele immer länger werden im Laufe der Zeit. Dass die früher kürzer waren, weil die Leute sich immer mehr Zeit lassen, weil die immer weniger zu tun haben. Lust haben. Weil die langsam merken, dass es ein extrem langweiliger Sport ist. Und es gibt halt so eine Zeitbegrenzung, bis du den Ball geworfen haben musst. Du kriegst den Ball und es ist ja nicht so wie beim Fussball, 90 Minuten, dann ist aus, sondern es ist ja so Innings und Sätze und blaue Kram. Das heißt, du kannst ja einfach eine Minute warten, bevor du den Ball wirst. Und warten die halt und dann wirft der den Ball daneben. Oh, nochmal, die Dose nicht getroffen Das ist so ein Sport, wo auf den Rängen schon so andere Sachen am Laufen sind. So Leute fangen dann an plötzlich irgendwie mit Aktien zu handeln und neben dem Ball irgendwie so einen Scheiss zu machen, Volleyball zu spielen. Wo die Zuschauer dann Volleyball spielen in den Zuschauerrängen, damit sie eine Unterhalte haben. Genau, schon so eigene eigene Spieler am Laufen haben, irgendwie das Spiel nachspielen, weil das eh so lange dauert. Und auf das Spiel wetten dann. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, die Sport Sportkultur ist ja in Amerika auch generell ganz anders. Ja, das stimmt. Oder? Ist mir auch schon mal eingefallen. Aufgefallen. Mir fallen heute immer die falschen Wörter ein. Ich habe keine Lust mehr, ich gehe jetzt. Oder bei Stefan. Jetzt muss ich ihn wieder tragen. Mit seinem Jetpack. Bist du mit deinem Segway gekommen? Du wolltest heute eigentlich mit deinem Segway kommen? Da hat sich Stefan mal gedacht, heute mal, heute ist ja die Sonne. Heute ziehe ich meine kurze Hose an, heute setze ich mein lustiges Cabby mit dem Propeller obendrauf an und fahre mit meinem Swagway wildflitzend sausend fast sogar. Ich bin indirekt mit meinem Segway gekommen, ich bin mit meinem Auto gekommen und im Kofferraum liegt das Swagway. Live in la vida loca. Wir haben letzte Woche angefangen, die Gag-Challenge zu machen. War ein bisschen Alkohol drin im Eis, oder? War ein bisschen was reingemacht vorher. Eine Kleinigkeit. Gag-Challenge. Du kriegst von mir eine Feedline und du musst darauf möglichst schnell eine Punchline geben. Wir ziehen das jetzt durch, bis es klappt. Wir machen drei, jeder macht drei. Wollen wir nicht einen Jingle machen oder so? Das ist mega lame so. Okay, okay, okay, Jingle. Während, ähm, warum … Während … Wessen Portemonnaie …
Während in Brüssel die Verhandlungen laufen, sehen wir in Kiel einen Mann mit einem schwarzen Koffer in der linken Hand.
Die Frage, warum … Warum?
Ähm, welches Eis bestellt sich der Elefant?
Äh, Türemisu.
Okay.
Ähm, gestern ist der Vaterschaftstesttürke gekommen.
Stellt sich raus... Ich habe ihn falsch adressiert. Wow. Ähm … Was solltest du noch in dein Stand-up einbauen, nach jeder Pointe? Wow! Die Anwaltskosten wurden sehr hoch. Na, das ist keine Feedline. Mein Anwalt sagte zu mir, das können Sie nicht tun, daraufhin habe ich. Bin ich in eine Bar gegangen und habe zu dem Barke gesagt, jetzt hör mal zu, Rui, die Sache mit uns, das geht jetzt schon zu lange. Ich komme jedes Mal her, du sagst, du leistest mir Geld und am Ende zeigst du das Geld nicht wieder. Ich habe ein schlechtes Gewissen, ja, und ich weiß nicht warum, du mir immer wieder Geld gibst, aber ich bin eigentlich eine Fledermaus und kann gar nicht reden. Sehr gut. Okay. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einer Leiter und einem Blauwal. Schwierig. Ja. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Wolken und einem Zaun? Kann ich dann auch fragen. Einfach mal. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Wolken und einem Zaun? Worum geht es eigentlich in eurem Podcast so? Stille, relativ viel. Wir beantworten Fragen, wir fragen, stellen sich die Fragen. Und dann denken wir nach und dann kommen wir zu einer Antwort. Das ist auch, glaube ich, keine gute Vielheit. Ich glaube, man muss eher sowas sagen wie die Dinge, zu denen man schon Assoziationen hat. Achso, und Wahl und Leiter, was verleiht es genau, die Assoziationen hat … Also ne, was …
Ach so, und Wahl und Leiter, was war jetzt genau die Assoziationen, die man dazu hat?
Ja, das war auch falsch. Wir nehmen noch mal beide eine Runde zurück. Okay. Dann mache ich noch mal neu. Was sagt der Schwarze zu dem Erfinder des Kugelschreibers? Heisst Blanc-Weiss, Blanc-Blanc-Blanc geschrieben?
Ja. Hat der Erfinder von Mont Blanc auch den Kugelschreiber erfunden? Nein. Mont Blanc ist ein Berg. Dann weiß ich nicht. Ja, Mont Blanc ist auch eine... Ich möchte lösen. Mont Blanc ist auch eine Kugelschreibermarke, nämlich. Ja, und was wäre dann der Gag? Der Gag wäre dann, können Sie Mont Blanc nicht ... was heißt, schwarz auf Französisch? Moir. Das ganze Bit weist man gesagt. Publikum noch mal. Sorry, was heißt nochmal schwarz auf Französisch? Hast du diese Rubrik? Was sagt ein Bauarbeiter, als eine Frau vorbeigeht? Ähm, zeig mir deine inneren Werte. Trenner. Wop, bo, bo, bo. Kommen wir nun zu unserer nächsten Rubrik, dem Freeze. Wir haben uns heute was überlegt, und zwar rufen wir bei einem ahnungslosen Opfer an und überlegen was das. Wir decken uns eine spannende Geschichte. Macht euch bereit auf ein bisschen Fremdscham, ein bisschen Spaß und ein bisschen Verzeihung. Dem Freestyle! Ja, es ist soweit. Seit der fünften Folge, glaube ich, haben wir uns nicht mehr ans Mic gewagt,
aber wir haben geübt parallel, weil wir sind uns entschuldig.
denn wir haben intern ein bisschen verzagt, doch haben wir es nicht verlernt, denn gelernt ist gelernt.
Spaß nicht vergleich. Wir haben jetzt folgende Idee gehabt, wir können auf normalen Beats nicht rappen,
da sind wir so schlecht, aber wir sind uns euch schuldig zu zeigen, wie wir Fortschritte machen,
denn wir machen welche, weil wir üben fleissig und deswegen haben wir einen Beat, einen sehr langsamen Beat rausgesucht. Und jetzt wünsche ich euch viel Spaß. Okay, warte. Okay, wir machen den Beat auf halber Geschwindigkeit. Okay, aber wir brauchen Thema, weil sonst... A, B, C... Nee, nee, nee, A, A, B, B, Sonst funktioniert das nicht. Ach ja, genau. Okay, wir brauchen eine Geschichte, wir erzählen… AG, F… DEF, DB. DEF, okay. Nee, lass es mal vielleicht einfach… Nee, aber sonst beschreiben wir nur Dinge, die im Raum sind und wie wir aussehen und dass wir heute Abend noch mal in den Zoo gehen. So, und das hat die Leute eigentlich gesagt. Also ein Thema ist Untergang. Untergang ist ein bisschen zu grob. Wir sagen einfach... Umweltbewusstsein. Thema Umweltbewusstsein. Okay, geht auf feibergischen... Okay. Okay. Ich vor allem? Mein Name ist Name ist Stefan, das Pfand steht für Spaß, die Sonne scheint und grün ist das Gras. Hey, mein Name ist Bernd und wir sind keine Lappen, wir kümmern uns intensiv für den Erhalt der Polkappen.
Wir glauben, da liegt viel Potential, es sterben viele Tiere aus, auch der Wahl.
Das ist ein Scheiß-Thema.
Nein, überhaupt, bitte nein!
Nein, man braucht eine Handlung, man braucht irgendeine Handlung, es muss irgendwas passieren.
Okay, okay, okay, ich gehe in den Supermarkt und weiss nicht, was ich kaufen soll.
Vielen Dank. Nein, man braucht eine Handlung, man braucht irgendeine Handlung, es muss irgendwas passieren. Okay, okay, okay. Ich gehe in den Supermarkt und weiss nicht, was ich kaufen soll. Okay. Okay. Okay. Ich gehe heute los. Mein Ziel heisst Edeka, ich weiss, was ich möchte, alles klar. Der Trip wird spannend, da bin ich mir sicher, ich weiss nur nicht, wo sind denn hier die Tiefkühlfächer. Ich schreife um die Gänge und suche alles ab, ich muss mich etwas beeilen, meine Zeit ist knapp. Ich hol mir Kinderriegel, die mag ich so sehr, aber ich kann mich nicht entscheiden, nehme ich vielleicht auch eine Milchschnitte, das ist schwer. Ich schaue mich um und sehe weit und breit keine Milchschnitte, doch am Kühlfach, da seh ich ne heisse Schnitte. Oh Mann, wie spreche ich sie bloss an, das fällt mir so schwer, ich bin ein schüchterner Mann. Hoffentlich ist ihr klar, ich bin erfolgreich auf Twitter, sie sieht zwar ganz süss aus, aber schmeckt ein bisschen bitter. Ich hätte sie vielleicht nicht anlecken sollen, das ist inakzeptabel, das Frauen nicht wollen. Ich frage sie, was machst du hier? Sie sagt, ich hab nen Freund. Ich dachte das Gespräch anders, als es jetzt läuft. Ich glaube, ich habe ihr die Luft zum Atmen genommen. Und jetzt hat sie mich gehauen und ich sehe nur noch verschwommen. Ich gestehe ein und sag, wir sollten uns andere Leute sehen, sie sagt, ja, das wäre mir echt bequem. Ich setze meinen Einkauf fort und gehe zu Getränken und dann frage ich mich, soll ich ihr vielleicht einen Sekt schenken? Die Antwort rautet nein relativ schnell in meinem Kopf. Ich bin mir sicher, auch sie hat nen schönen Zopf. Es ist mir aufgefallen, ihre Haare waren blond, oh, da sehe ich die Die DVDs und die haben James Bond. Hey, ho, yes, yo, ich hol mir die DVD noch in den Korb, bevor ich wieder geh. Kasse zwei ist leer, ich stell mich hinten an und dann lege ich die Sachen auf das Kassenband an. Das einzige, was fehlt, ist ein Kundendifferenzierungsmodul. Ich lege es auf das Band. Mann, ist das cool! Das war der coolste Einkauf, den ich jemals hatte. Und dann leg ich mir die Sonne auf die Platte. Ich will den Supermarkt verlassen, ich komme nicht durch die Tür, diese Lichtschranke ist schwer, für mich die reinste Qual. Ich gehe also noch mal durch den ganzen Markt und gehe vorne aus der Türe, ja, wie ich das mag. Ich laufe die Strasse entlang bis zum Strassenübergang.
Ich glaube, ich habe die Bananen vergessen.
Oh nein, wie mache ich jetzt nur, das ist echt beschissen!
Ich vergass noch zu erwähnen, welcher Tag heute ist.
Es ist neunzehnsechsenneunzig, meine Freundin ist weg und bräunt sich in der Südsee oder auf Madagaskar. Ich steige ein in mein Auto, ich fahre einen Ford-Car. Dachte, du sagst Ford Fiesta, aber auch dein Reim ging ziemlich klar. Moment, ist das jetzt ein Privatgespräch zwischen uns beiden? Weil das würde ich nicht wollen, lass uns das mal lieber bleiben. Vielleicht hast du recht, es war eine schlechte Idee, drum steige ich in mein Auto und schiebe eine CD ins CD-Laufwerk. Um sie anzuhören. Ja, schon gleich. Ich muss warten bis deine Zeile vorbei. Wie lange ist dieser Song, ey? Ich höre die von Aber, die mag ich so sehr, ich fahre um die Ecke und anschliessend in den Kreisverkehr. Yeah! Alter, wir haben's durchgezogen. Wow, wow, wow, represent! Yo, yo, yo! Nieses Mal ein bisschen schneller. Ups, off, okay, sorry, das war was ganz anderes. Ja! Wie hat es euch gefallen, schreibt es in die Kommentare, gebt uns einen Daumen nach oben, abonniert uns. Schreibt uns in die Comments, schreibt uns mal eine Mail. Wir kriegen echt wenige Mail, aber wir kriegen tatsächlich viele Fehlermeldungen. Wir kriegen weniger Postkarten als Meldungen, als Meldungen. Weil es ist tatsächlich, wir müssen auch jetzt mal ein ernstes Thema ansprechen. Ja, nicht mal Gags, Gags, Gags, auch mal Ernst, Ernst, Ernst, Ernst, Ernst, Ernst, Ernst, Serious Business! Nächste Runde rückwärts! Ernste Themen ernst verpackt mit Stefan und Stefan Timolo! In der nächsten Stunde hört ihr noch Live-as-Rollcoaster und Maroon 5 mit Pay-n-it-Lav. Und jetzt hat es mal viel Spaß mit Mara Camado. Bis gleich. Ciao. Und da sind wir wieder. Das war Candle for Dottie von Mara Camado. Stefan, hast du eigentlich schon mitbekommen, was gerade los ist? Ich sag mal wieder, die Nachrichtenwelt spielt crazy, crazy weird.
This is crazy.
Was war denn da los in Hamburg? Hast du es gelesen in der Zeitung?
Ja, ein riesen Tsunami. Oh mein Gott, wie könnte das denn passieren?
Ich weiß nicht, was da los war.
Oh mein Gott, so viel Wasser habe ich das letzte Mal gesehen, als seine Mutter in den Pool gesprungen ist.
Oh mein Gott, weird, he didn't say that. Uuuuuh, pschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschsch nicht die Public- Mareike Amado? Die hat doch die, wie heisst die nochmal, die Karaoke- nee, Kinder-Playback-Playback-Show. Weisst du, wie es klingt? Mareike Amado klingt wie Dagmar Fernandez oder so. Aber es passt überhaupt nicht zusammen. Mareike Amado. Die hat doch die Pico-Playback-Show. Ganz ehrlich, eine Kindersendung im Fernsehen, wo Kinder sich vor laufender Kamera umziehen, als ob das nicht offensichtlich an eine pädophile Zielgruppe gerichtet ist. Kann man damit drüber reden oder ist es noch ein Tabu? Wohl eher Mareike Amapedo. Oh mein Gott, he didn't say that. Die Bienen, yes he did, you have to be cool fooling me, cause that's too crazy. Wollen wir so Gadgets, die einspielen manchmal. AstroTV. Ja, ja, ich weiss. Ich habe es gehört. Angenommen, also ich denke mir immer, die entscheiden ja gerade spontan, was sie demjenigen sagen wollen, der an der anderen Leitung ist. Angenommen, die haben einen schlechten Tag. Dann würde ich, wenn ich einen schlechten Tag hätte, würde ich das an den Leuten auslassen, denen ich die Zukunft vorhersage. Dann würde ich so etwas sagen wie, ja kriege ich mein Geld zurück, nein, nein, sie kriegen nicht nur ihr Geld nicht zurück, sie werden noch mehr verlieren. Noch mehr verlieren, sie werden schwanger und werden das Kind gebärbt und es wird sofort verbrennen, es wird noch im Krankenhaus verbrennen. Weil das Krankenhaus, wo auch ihr Mann übrigens drin liegt, weil er sich vorher in den Kopf gestossen hat, eigentlich La Paliali, aber er ist auch gestorben. Ihr Mann hat es in Brand gesetzt, mit 14 Liter Benzin. Ja, geklaut, das hat er geklaut hat vorher, wofür sie jetzt belangt werden. Sie mussten sogar dafür bezahlen. Ja, also eigentlich alles gut, ne, tschüss. Oh, ich sehe gerade, die Zeit fliegt, aber Mensch, hu, ah, tut mir leid, wir hätten leider gerne noch weiter gemacht, aber wir müssen leider los, Stefan. Wir müssen den Raum verlassen, weil jetzt gerade auch andere Leute hier reinkommen. Da kommen jetzt so eine ganze Schiffklasse lauter Pfadfinderinnen. Wir kommen gleich, wir kommen gleich rein, wir kommen gleich raus. Sorry. Leg das mal ganz kurz weg, wir kommen gleich. Alles klar, gut, bis gleich. So, wir müssen noch ganz kurz abmoderieren. Also, das war die 18. und 19. Folge von Podcastliste Nucularbahn.
Nee, diese Folge war ein Gastvertrag von Gastliste Geisterbahn.
Sorry, wenn es nicht ganz so gut war, weil wir haben ein Skript von denen bekommen.
Aber die haben das gut gemacht mit den Stimmen, die haben echt unsere Stimmen sehr gut imitiert.
Alles klar.
Okay, dann denk an das Spielspiel und bis nächste Woche.
Macht gut, bis zum Glück. Продолжение следует...